hello everyone this video was suggested
to me by Grandmaster Todd Barone of
Israel and Barone is a pretty cool guy
and well he's also a very very strong
chess player I will put a link in the
description below so you can check out
some of his content you know if you want
I'm sure you could learn a lot from the
guy and well I said okay dad that is a
pretty good idea for a video but okay
I'll do it and I thought that okay I
will show you the game and then I will
put the video with the original footage
in the description below and I remember
seeing this footage of this particular
event and I remember seeing the moment
when Kasparov drops the piece and Judith
was very displeased with what Kasparov
has done but I searched the entire
Internet and I cannot find any evidence
of this footage other than you know
people in forum asking what happened to
the footage which is very strange
because well popular videos don't just
disappear from YouTube and well I
thought it doesn't really matter I'm
sure some of you as you are huge chest
fans do probably have this video footage
somewhere either on your computer or
somewhere stored and I you know I invite
you to send this footage to me so I can
put it in the description below thank
you in advance so let's see this game
this was played in 1994 it was the
linearis tournament some of the
strongest players in history played in
this tournament
Karpov actually won the tournament full
two and a half points ahead of Kasparov
and Kasparov shared a second and third
place with Alexei Scheer of vastly von
Schuch who got 10th place and well Jorge
bowler in the end was second-to-last but
this is round five and she's playing
against the world champion Garry
Kasparov in the first four rounds
Judith actually had two points out of
four points so she was at 50%
performance which is you know quite
excellent as she was only 17 years old
and this is her first tournament of this
strength and yeah it's probably after
this event with Garry Kasparov that she
started
you know playing not so well but let's
see this game and this famous historical
moment Judith is white and the garry
kasparov is black we have efore c5
Knight to f3 d6 so the Sicilian v4c
captor sang before Knight captures and
e4 Knight to f6 Knight c3 we have eight
a six so the knight of variation f4 and
east six transposing into there
Scheveningen variation Bishop to e2
Bishop to e7 and vulgare castles and we
have Queen to c7 and this is a standard
setup of the Scheveningen the queen will
be very useful in c7 as at some point
this rook will come to c8 it will add
pressure to the c2 pawn and also it
prevents white from any early e5 ideas
we have Queen t1 by Judith Knight B to
d7 and now a for not allowing as part of
to play b5 so he plays B 6 and we have
Bishop to f3 adding protection to this
e5 pawn as a casparo will now attack it
Bishop to b7 developing the light square
bishop and also adding pressure to the
e4 pawn we have King - h1 and this is
always a useful move to play as Michael
Todd once said that if you're playing
against black in the Sicilian and blacks
Queen can somehow reach the c5 square
always play King gauge 1 or or you'll be
sorry
one way or the other so we have worked
to d8 by Kasparov and the Bishop to e3
and knock was part of castles and well
George plays Queen to g3 she's ready to
go for the attack she doesn't mind she's
playing against the world champion and
well the threat is pretty
straightforward
it's a bar a barbaric one it's f5 and
Bishop to h6 going for this g7 pawn so
power plays Knights the c5 he he has
another attacker to this e4 pawn now
he's attacking it three times but to
Judith doesn't match place f5 with her
initial threat of Bishop 286 and well it
does seem like a sparrow can capture a
point here but let's see what happens if
he does if he plays Knight captures on C
on e4 we get knife captures on e4 Knight
captures on e4 Bishop captures on e4 and
of course Bishop captures on e4 by
casparo and now f6 and unfortunately
forecast part of this would win a point
if he decided to do this because well
this point is pinned and what is
threatening checkmate on g7 so Bishop
captures and f6 and rook captures on a6
and well this is winning a piece so
after this f5 move Kasparov decided to
go for e5 and okay Judy continuous with
her plan he prepare she plays Bishop to
h6 now threatening checkmate on g7 and
we have knife to e8 defending Knight to
b3 and well she doesn't mind if casparo
would capture this night as then seek
after Sun v3 this opponent c2 would no
longer be a liability this night could
move so workers power decides not to do
this he plays Knight to d7
we have rook 8 d1 and the King to h8 now
this point is no longer pinned now has
power can capture the bishop so Bishop
Act III and Knight to f6 we have Queen
to f2 adding pressure to this b6 born so
now this night is kind of obligated to
stay on d7 we have rook F to e8
centralizing the rooks and the Judit
follows up with this rook F to e 1 also
centralizing her rooks and our Bishop to
f8 Bishop to f8 probably would ideas of
d5 as there's a very old saying that if
you're able to push d5 when playing the
Sicilian you'll be okay so something
like d5e capture sandy fun and then e
for maybe butchered it stops this any d5
idea she plays Bishop to g5 and we have
h 6 by Kasparov and Bishop to h4 still
opening this night here and casparo goes
rook to c8 unpinning and the world now
adding more pressure to the c2 pawn as
now this Knight really can't move and we
have Queen to f1 by Judith we have
Bishop to e7 and Knight d2 and this
night to D - well this is a
it was already time trouble for Judith
both for Judith in Kasparov and I really
I I see no sense in this night 2d to
move as this night was very nicely
protecting c5 here and now conspire
immediately jumps a queen to c5 with
ideas of Queen before an Queen captures
and b2 here George goes back tonight b3
and now attacking the Queen again and we
have Queen to b4 and the Queen I don't
know there are a lot of pieces around
Kasparov queen but there is no way to
capture the Queen and now not just place
a Bishop to e2 she gives up this central
pawn for capturing this a6 pawn what
it's not really the best idea but it was
in time trouble so Casper grabs at
Bishop captures on e4 Knight captures on
e4 and we have knife captors in e4
Bishop captures on e7 captures any
seventh so a whole series of trades and
well now of course not capturing the a
six point with the bishop because your
if a four point is hanging first Judah
plays Bishop to f3 now attacking this
Knight twice and Kaspar plays Knight to
f6 and now capturing the a six point
with the Queen and also protecting a
four so we have rook to e8 Queen back to
e2 and the well we have King to g8
Bishop to b7 now attacking that rock and
see it and rook the c5 and here Queen to
d2 and George is offering an exchange of
Queens but if as part of well the
clients then this d6 pawn will be
grabbed so cos probably clients at Queen
captures on a4 and rook captures on d6
or Queen captures on d6 rook captures
and c2 and well okay because part of is
better in this position now he's
attacking this b3 night he just grabbed
the pawn here on c2 so he's now
officially up a pawn and in this
position Judith played what probably the
only move play Knight to d2 and this is
the this is the famous position
everybody was talking about and the
position were you
I couldn't find the original video
footage to link in the description and
like I said please do send it to me if
you have it in this position
Kasparov played Knight the c5 well he
kind of played it he let go of the piece
and then well he grabbed the piece again
and played another move but it was it
was a it was a very short time the piece
was actually out of his hand they say
like quarter of a second but it was
recorded on tape now Kasparov says that
he wasn't aware of this and that he
didn't realize the piece left his hand
but I remember seeing in the original
footage that Judith was very displeased
when Kasparov did this and you know she
you could see that she was angry but
later after after the game Kasparov
actually said that he he wasn't worried
of this because the whole point at night
Knight to c5 is a bad move is Bishop to
c6 now attacking the Queen and the rook
here but Kasparov said that he didn't
really mind this Bishop to c6 move at
all because he had Queen to h4 now did
he really see this over the board during
time trouble or did he you know sorry
figure it out after the game I don't
know we can never tell really the idea
is that after Bishop captures on e8
Knight the g4 is here threatening
checkmate on h2 and this is this is a
completely wrong position doesn't matter
what white plays or or you know if good
moves are played this will be a draw for
example if h3 then simply Knight to have
to check King g1 Knight captures 83 with
check G captures Knight and queens g3
and well this will be a perpetual
wherever the King goes the Queen follows
and even if after Knight to g4 why
decides to go for something like well
not h3 but for example Bishop captures
on f7 again King captures on f7 and well
now h3 and we get the same thing Knight
f2 and this is well at least a draw for
black but again it's very hard to say
that Kasparov
that after for example a move like after
I move like king to g1 sorry sorry about
this after a move like King to g1 that
he couldn't capture this rook on d1 here
because now white is completely winning
this position for example rook captures
any on e5 and well this is now
completely winning for Judith he can try
a move like well Queen have to check but
after a king - h1 there are no more
moves for Kasparov here and well there
is it's very hard to defend the threat
of Queen to g6 check and wrote the DA
checkmate
so it's well it's very hard to say if he
did see all this during the game so
after this night the D to move Kasparov
did play Knight to c5 but then he
immediately grabbed the piece and
retrieved it to f8 and now this bishop
the c6 idea is no longer possible
because the rook is now covering the c6
square so here George played a knife to
e4 we have night eight to d7 as powerful
goes back we have a Knight captures on
f6 Knight captures on f6 and Queen
capture some b6 here Kasparov plays
Knight to g4 we have rook to F 1 we have
efore by Kasparov now the threat is of
course III and E - we have Bishop to d5
now Judith is threatening Bishop to b3
with an attack on the Queen and the rook
but Kasparov totally disregards this he
plays III we have Bishop to b3 now
attacking the Queen and rook
but now Queen to e4 so Bishop captures
and c2 Queen captures and c2 and Judith
plays rook to d8 so we have rook
captures and e8 Queen captures and e8
and now King to h7 and the well it's a
very dangerous for white here this is
very unpleasant to play in this position
Judith plays Queen to e7 and well here
Kasparov played Queen to c4 and in this
position Judith had to resign the game
whatever whatever she plays this is
completely winning for
as this rook is being attacked by the
Queen the rook has to move so best best
would be to play something like rook to
a-1 although it doesn't really matter
what what white plays and well here
Queen f4 is simply devastating
threatening checkmate here on h2 so yeah
well we can show for example King to g1
I don't know there aren't really any
good moves to defend this and now e2 is
coming and while this is very very
unpleasant for example Queen to h4 Queen
e3 check King h1 and now check and well
this loses the Queen so yeah that's the
game although it didn't go all the way
to here after this Queen to f4 move
Judith sorry after the screen to see
four move George Spota resigned the game
and like I said she did go into this
round five with a 50% performance and
after this game it didn't really go all
that well for her so this game really
probably did take a toll on her and she
said that she didn't really want to make
a build the big deal out of it during
the game as this is the first time she
was invited to play in such a strong
tournament and well she she was playing
the world champion and she said that she
was afraid of if her appeal was
overruled that she would lose time on
the clock and she was already in time
trouble so she didn't really react to
this and yeah one more thing the the
video footage shows that the arbiter was
standing next to them when this incident
happened but the arbiter - claims that
he didn't see Kasparov actually dropped
a piece so yeah that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed it maybe some of you
have even more information on this
incident
like I said if you do have the video
footage please please do send it to me
or just link it in the comments and yeah
that's it as usual you can check to my
previous videos here thank y'all for
watching and I will see you soon